hi my name is celani and i've been
teaching science for five years i'm
nicholas froni
i'm a high school history teacher and
i've been teaching for 18 years
i also have a tick tock of my own
stylani love
of course i'm crazy i shouldn't be
having one but you know teachers got to
have fun too i will be honest i only
have a tick tock because my students
encourage me to
and honestly we actually use it in class
so it is a useful educational tool
nobody
all right that's pretty that's pretty
intention nobody's doing that anymore
with coronavirus though
i did have teachers do that while i was
a student i i don't lick my fingers when
uh when i'm passing out anything
even before coronavirus because i'm a
science teacher i'm very paranoid about
germs
so nobody's licking anything in my
classroom but it is very funny though
so can anyone tell me what the author
might have meant
in this paragraph alyssa
they got a response quick okay this is
that quick
well not quite
okay not quite you're on the right track
all right this is the right track and
this is you
you're on the right track but not quite
teachers are very good at
telling students who got a wrong answer
saying something wrong that it's not
wrong
you don't want to discourage them from
speaking out
i'm not that dramatic i think that's
really it i know somebody at my school
couple teachers that are like that all
the time
welcome student to the first day
of online school
this is your principal ma
and your prom date principal and
probably
lunch today is whatever you make
yourself
and just mom is that sure oh no see how
we get so annoyed together
happy first day of school i'm a teacher
and i'm a mom and my son would get so
annoyed if i did that
to the parents who are who are going
through this my heart's with you this is
so tough
and we appreciate you so much we also
know that you appreciate us a lot more
too
[Music]
that's funny i have definitely left a
class when i wasn't supposed to
i said i had a doctor's appointment but
i was just very tired
but it's because i work really hard i
can relate to this because there are
times i'm sure all teachers when our
tech and stuff is falling apart and
we're tempted to leave
struggle is real i took a nap
because i thought i had time to take a
nap and then finish my homework
um it auto-submitted
but the worst part is that the final
question was voice based
and i only recorded one and i was
[ __ ] around with it to see how my mic
was
and the only thing i recorded was
talented it do cartwheels
so my spanish teacher is going to look
at that and hear
he talented into cartwheels and he paid
because he liked how that part fails
oh my god
well he's in trouble but it was cute
though i mean he's talented he might be
into being a rapper i'll be honest i
haven't had any students turn anything
inappropriate what i do have students
i'm sure teachers can relate
is we have students press the turn
button and submit their work but they
don't attach anything i've had plenty of
students uh doing some weird stuff
online
doing the online learning i've had uh
random farts noises
me hearing things that i shouldn't hear
with the parents in the background
like jimmy don't leave your dirty
underwear in the bathroom
don't need to know that i wake up in the
morning
i turn off my video
pay attention no i haven't really
learned anything all semester
i feel that i understand that feeling
this is the most relatable video i've
ever seen
keep making videos like that maybe
you'll become famous no i'm just kidding
our class wanted to surprise our
professor so we
start off with the cameras off
it's so sweet you know this is what i'm
here for
oh that's so cute what a sweet what's
sweet
students this chokes me up because this
is why we do we do
and i have no doubt that that professor
[Music]
he could have probably had so many
stressful days and his teachers i get
one email from a student changes my
entire day it changes my entire year
i just think it's a really nice thing if
you guys want to do something nice for
your teacher okay just put up a sign and
say thank you two weeks ago i was
going through a lot of stress from my
father my father was going through
an illness and he's struggling once i
logged off class i broke down
because the weight of my dad kind of set
in uh within three minutes i got an
imminence
choking mapping said i got an email from
one of my students saying
you know you always check in on us but
you looked really upset today
i just want to make sure you're okay and
i can't really do much to support you
but
i appreciate you so much and i hope
you're okay you know our students keep
us going
you know it's like they're such great
human beings so if you are a student
a simple email you have no idea how much
of an impact that will have on your
teacher
we're not in this for the pay we're not
in this for the fame but a small gesture
like that
will forever change their their not only
their attitude
about what they're doing but it just
reinforces why we do what we do
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you